lance mccullers jr taking the hill today
lance has 72 and two-thirds innings
pitched this season has only allowed 50
hits
swing and a miss what an electric start
to an afternoon contest as lance
mccullers jr strikes out ramon laureato
on three pitches
that was a fast ball and it's hit down
the third base line headed for the left
field corner
alvarez will pick it up
and alva sanders has a one out double
olson homered in the first inning last
night
colors from the wind up
and that ball's hit down the left field
line
shallow and it drops fair it's going to
be an rbi double as anders trots in to
score
ball
just fair and then took a big hop into
the seats and the a's have a one-nothing
lead
lowry checks in so back-to-back doubles
by elvis and olsen in the ace have the
early lead
two-two pitch is grounded up the middle
and that's gonna get through into center
field olson rounds third he's gonna head
on home and it's two to nothing the a's
lead frankie montos needs a good start
and he'd love to do that against the
astros where a team has had success
he gets el touve to chase down and away
and that's a swing and a miss 97 miles
an hour right on the outside corner
strike three called right on the inside
corner another perfect pitch by frankie
montoz
3-1 pitch
not close it's a lead-off walk
called third strike beautiful pitch by
mccullars froze aramis garcia
fairball and it's under the glove of
toro bounces off the side wall
brown is going to go to third he'll make
it and loriano's got a double
andrew sends one to right field pretty
deep kyle tucker makes the play in front
of the wall for the final out of the
inning
oh two pitch that's a swing and a missed
by jordan alvarez and right now frankie
montas knows nothing but strikeouts
there's a ball roped into center field
julie guriel gets the astros their first
base runner of the game
three two pitches off the plate ball
four
[Applause]
good pitch swing and a miss and that is
strikeout number five for frankie
there's a pretty pitch lance mccullers
junior freezes matt olsen
lowry hits it hard into center field and
that's a base hit so judd lowry's two
for two
swing and a miss lance mccullers jr with
a couple of strikeouts in the inning one
hit allowed
here's a 3-1 inside ball four
and kept with speed as a board and the
a's have been frisky in that regard
bounce toward third little juggle by
toro and then he throws high did gurio
get the tag he did the out
is recorded at first although the a's
are not completely sold on it and
they're gonna rule that he is safe
high in the air to left but it's
playable as alvarez now comes in he
makes the catch so these
strand a pair
and put him away
strikeout number eight
and there it was
and it rolls past garcia alvarez
hustling to first the throw is in time
there's a base hit the one guy who's
been able to solve frankie montas is
yuli guriel
who is now two for two the leg kick the
one two
splitters swinging a miss down goes
tucker ten strikeouts and
a masterful performance so far today for
frankie motas
and that's lifted shallow right kept
going out but that's going to fall in
safely and chas mccormick has the astros
third hit it's a lead off single
runner goes [ __ ] up and away garcia's
throw is in time they got him three two
and that breaking ball drops in for
strike three tony kemp was walking back
to the third base dugout what color is
the kick in the pitch and the breaking
ball drops in for strike three garcia
goes down looking seven punch-outs from
the colors
alva sandra stays with it spins around
throws to olson and that's out number
two
olson's got it olson will trot to the
bag and another good inning for frankie
montoz
up the middle and that's a base hit into
center field for alves anders he's two
for four
oh two frozen
little change piece on the outside
corner lance picks up strikeout number
eight
mccullers has the sign here comes the
one two runner goes the pitch and it's
pulled and it's caught by gurio
[Applause]
first pitch
bounced right to amherst with the shift
on
alvarez one pitch
one out here in the seventh
that one hit hard torch out he's got it
behind the bag shows off the good arm
and a close play
guriel is retired for the first time
today and that's two outs in the bottom
of the seventh here comes the 2-2
that one's pulled to the right side
coming in for it is biscotti and he
can't get there
it squirts past him tucker goes to
second
on the valiant effort by piscotty
now looking at the potential tying run
at the plate and it's chas mccormick
that one bounces in there and tucker
will take advantage he'll advance to
third with two away
sharply head fair ball down the left
field line into the corner
chaz mccormick with an rbi double astros
trail 2-1
so that's gonna do it for frankie montoz
as he was very good today six and two
thirds innings gives up the one run
seven and one 3.25 era for petite he
pitched on tuesday game one of the
series
2-2 pitch is grounded to chap chapman's
got it he throws and olson has to dig it
out
so a run on two hits for the astros
eighth inning coming up it's now two to
one a's andre scrub will be in there to
pitch the eighth after lance mccullers
jr goes seven innings today
swing and a miss andre scrub getting
matt chapman swinging for the first out
here in the eighth inning
swing and a miss scrub
95 mile an hour cutter back-to-back
strikeouts astros with 10 strikeouts as
a staff
trevino comes in for his 40th appearance
he's 3-3 2.01 era first at bat of this
series against the a's
up and away ball four castro draws a
walk
he represents the tying run
in the bottom half of the eighth inning
this one bounced in the hole that was
sanders throws to second out
popped it up
right side of the diamond
camp waits and he's got it nice job by
lou trevino after issuing the lead-off
walk trevino worked the eighth and now
diekmann in the ninth
first pitch and that's a ground ball
against the shift past the dive of
andrews and then the center for a base
hit
bounce to short elvis has it second for
one on the first double play
tucker on a soft line drive tony kim
dives he's got it and that's the ball
game